foreign
[Music]
don't talk to me I won't
oh that's the first step first step of
the day it's the first sip of the day
you didn't have a sip of coffee before
we came in here I don't drink yeah I
don't know ah dude I can't get out of
the house
goddamn my coffee
yeah I've sort of trained myself to not
have it first thing plus I have my beans
that I like I got my grinds that I like
now are you are you still making it in
the in the Keurig or the or the
Nespresso machine no I'm grinding beans
oh you're doing the whole thing yeah
um the Joshua Tree coffee
loving Josh we treat coffee yeah love it
I think I've had that before so good
well that's okay damn is it tasty what's
that oh we're just chatting here buddy
we're chatting is Megan coming today or
no
oh
boys
excellent sorry we get to roast men
I'll say about Megan is she's gonna come
in she's not gonna find it funny
she is going to be sweating she's going
to be upset so how are we going to
navigate that we're going to lay right
into it
and we're going to push on it as hard as
we can absolutely because that's what
that's what friends are different
friends to friends do that's what
friends do they find somebody they find
the stress they find the pressure point
and they just go right out here she is
awesome
right on time she's on time you are
gonna get it you should see my parking
Job
full diagonal we should have Glenn
analyze it we were like wolves who
noticed one of the Wolves is like
limping
we were about to just attack but the
problem is what happens when you come
over the woods nine o'clock so she's on
time I'm on time the the metaphor was
would be you go over the wolf and it
turns out that she wasn't limping at all
oh she was trying to avoid you in so
that she could find out there are other
wolves behind you now and you're like
she wanted to figure out who the Wolves
were that were going to come is that
what was happening Meg uh no it's just
that you guys have forgotten that the
wolf can cut all this so yeah yeah
that's true this doesn't even have to
exist in the episode yeah I think it's
more like the wolf just like had a thorn
in its foot and the other wolves were
like oh maybe we'll get to eat this one
today and then she was like nah nah I
like got the thorn out and then the
other wolves were like oh okay okay
no that was a joke that was
you're fine a friendly ribbing and
[Music]
here we are I don't even know how to do
this well I'm sure Mike's got some sort
of structure I do yeah I do well yeah I
was thinking that we could discuss
Fool's Paradise first I've written
around a bunch of questions and then I
thought we could get to Blackberry
second that's probably
um because you're involved in both so
you won't be as bored in the first one
yeah I would think okay if that's all
right with you guys does that work out
for you that seems good to me I I was
really looking forward to this episode
because and hope all the creeps out
there will get to notice this because I
don't know if the listeners will but
it's going to be they I don't know if
they thought about this but it's going
to be very uncomfortable for them you
mean from a like a compliment yeah
because it's very hard it's very hard to
sit there and be complimented over and
over and over again I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it anyway but not because I
want to make them feel uncomfortable
because I'm so proud of them
I mean I I think I'll be more
comfortable with it than I was when we
were in front of 9 000 people in Dublin
and it was like I don't wanna sit here
and take it all right let's get to it
let's talk movies I do want to talk
about here we've all watched each
other's uh films and we're here to talk
about it um go
take a look at this guy what about him
he's a dead ringer for you man don't
look nothing like me I mean look at him
he's too short you can finish the day
for you
Pronto excuse me Mr Pronto can I call
you latte
hey latte Pronto latte Toronto is that
your name you and me are gonna do big
things about bad respect bro
moo Stop's coming through
um well I wanted to start by asking
Charlie uh how did this film come about
and it's sort of like a chicken egg
situation did you decide that you wanted
to write and direct something and then
came up with an idea for what you wanted
to write or direct or did you come up
with the idea first and then we're like
oh I'm the person to write and direct
this the funny thing about this thing is
I've been tinkering with it as sort of
like a passion thing for a decade so we
were on season 10 of the show and I was
starting to feel pretty confident and my
abilities write and execute something
and I'd done some rewrites on some
feature films that I've been able to act
in
um
but I'd also sort of realized I I didn't
have control over those films like that
the way that we have total control over
Sunny we have the final say so as I was
writing this movie I thought well if I
don't direct it
I might get in a situation where
someone's making it something I don't
want it to be and that would suck so it
was kind of realizing that I had to
direct it and then there was a piece of
me that forgive the comparison because
it's you know everyone's all up in arms
about it but I understand but like I
loved Woody Allen movies I I loved
Albert Brooks I loved things that seemed
like they were a singular voice from a
person so I I think I always wanted to
do that thing uh
and then I love certain types of movies
like being there which is obviously the
closest relative to this movie and I was
like I'm just never gonna get the
opportunity to be in a movie like that
they're not gonna make them uh and then
feeling like a certain kind of
style of movie was just not getting made
or even like a Coen Brothers movie or
Paul Thomas Anderson or do sort of tour
driven things being like well I don't
know if all might just may never ring
uh so a combination of just some
confidence with what we were doing
at Sunny
as a boot camp of how to do it and then
a desire to be in a certain type of
movie was the sort of initial like well
let's just try to make one I imagine too
is a type of movie where you're not
speaking in the movie not having control
over that thing would be doubly
impossible because it would be like you
lost your voice in two different ways
like to have somebody else tell you how
you're supposed to do a movie like that
yeah
well I just want to start by saying I
was so endlessly entertained by I've
always been a big fan of this movie in
its earliest iteration I mean you you
sent me a script for this for a version
of this yeah different but it had a lot
of the same elements that are sure it
was probably 60 60 to 70 percent of what
you're actually going to see in the in
the movie it was in that initial script
and certainly the style and the feel and
the comedic sensibility the the
Hollywood satire aspect of it so I've
been a fan of every single iteration of
this even you know when it was
you know this thing of like how do you
make a movie with a protagonist that
doesn't speak and doesn't want anything
which was and doesn't want but more even
more importantly doesn't want anything
yeah and is literally it literally
breaks the number one rule of
screenwriting which is having the main
character get pushed around get like
forced into other things being just just
like a vessel of other people's
motivations right and yet somehow like
that was the that was also the thing I
loved about it and that I still love
about the movie
um uh so I I just I just want to before
we start getting to all the questions I
just want to say like I just love the
film and man it's so funny I love I love
every single sequence it's never not
totally entertaining from beginning to
end you know and it's constantly like
opening itself up and you're meeting new
characters and like exploring different
sides of the business and uh you know
until it really spirals out of control
at the end sure you know and you get to
meet like the people behind it you know
yeah now was that yeah it's like I don't
want to totally give away but it's um
yeah you kind of Meet the uh you know
the people that make the people the
people that make the people yeah yeah
yeah but what you just touched on I
think is what is a good kind of primer
for people to understand before they go
into the movie and it makes it that much
more enjoyable that I think the idea
that the main character doesn't want
anything is the point of the movie
because I think yeah uh that you and I'm
taking this from the movie itself not
even conversations that we've had that I
think the idea is that people will
project what they want to onto the main
character right and so the audience is
doing that every character that's
surrounding the character is doing that
and they're creating something that is
just a reflection of themselves not the
person like I've never seen that before
even being there wasn't really quite
that no it's a slightly different thing
right where well it seemed to apply to
this town right which is yeah built on
Persona and ego I remember sitting and
thinking
I was reading an article about the Rock
and then I switched over to some other
entertainment article about Justin
Bieber and I was thinking what are these
names and how do we just accept them and
like you know it was talking about like
beavers and things and I was like that's
that's a strange sounding word now I
know that is that that man's name but
like the rock we just started calling a
man an inanimate object and we were just
well it sounds like he's a wrestler I
mean you know for sure but look at the
wrestling world there's a lot of that we
went for the ride right
um you know and he walks down the street
some of them will go there goes the Rock
and I was like what strange sort of a
concept like so the idea of a name and
an identity and what that is it just
seemed like fertile ground it's super
effective you know yeah because it it
creates a Mystique and a mystery and a
conversation you know the edge you know
the guitar player or slash yeah you know
it creates like wait wait this person
goes Madonna even you know I want a one
named you it doesn't compute because my
name is Rob mcelhenney yeah right which
is like very what if somebody else like
I want to be called mushy yeah I mean
everyone call me mushy I'm sure
someone's probably even tried that yeah
but then also there was something
interesting remember the story that I
think we were talking about maybe you
had overheard it where Jack Black was
like in a casting office and
he had just done like what was his
breakthrough movie it was um
uh High Fidelity yeah oh yeah right and
he heard someone saying get get me the
next show yeah yeah that's like the
Hollywood the Hollywood Story yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right this is this is the
progression of a Hollywood actor right
yeah Hollywood a famous Hollywood actor
it's who's Jack Black and then it's get
me Jack Black and then it's get me the
next Jack Black
who's Jack and then
it comes full circle so I I thought in
that already is an inherently
entertaining structure for just a a
story arc yes but then wait wait can you
tell the tell the creeps and listeners
what the inanimate object is because
that's I had an idea in writing this
this was in the very first draft and it
just stayed that like someone asked
someone for a latte Pronto they were
just always yelling for a latte Pronto
and then Ken who really drives the story
uh Ken Jeong overhears Ray Liotta asking
someone for a latte Pronto and assumes
he's talking to me and assumes my name
is latte Bronte so and then everyone
just starts calling me latte Pronto
which is actually a really cool name
this is a decent name yeah latte I
believe people would go for that yeah
but I think the introduction of hens
characters where the satire really gets
uh so much deeper because you know as
Rob was saying like there's this
projection that you can do on a
character with no wants or needs and so
you might if it were just latte Pronto
you might watch this movie and say oh
well uh that's just the wrong way to go
about things you actually should have
these wants and needs but then you have
Ken Jeong who is a character of nothing
but needs yes desperate ones and needs
yes and it was a real acting challenge
for Ken because you know he's known as
yeah listen I well that's one of the
things I wanted to talk about was his
performance in the film I I think those
those emotional moments are crucial to
making the movie work um me too I love
those moments in the movie I those
really grounded it for me Sam I think he
he gave a performance unlike anyone's
ever seen him give without a doubt and I
I think uh it caught me it really caught
me off guard it really caught me off
guard because again I've seen the movie
before but I haven't seen the newer
stuff that you shot where you added more
stuff with Canon and kind of doing the
things I essentially made him the main
character you know like or like split
right down the middle in a way yeah but
he's the protagonist right he's driving
the action and he goes on as much of a
of a rise and fall emotionally as my
character does but um with Ken I
remember saying to him listen people are
used to you doing a very sort of it's
almost like a sarcastic sassy uh sense
of Comedy that he does it's very funny
really when he does that it's really
funny and I was like Ken you can't do
this for this character you have to be a
thousand percent Earnest yeah you can
the character does some manipulation and
some lying but he has to do it in a very
Earnest very what was his reaction to
that like did he was he like I don't
know if was he worried that he wasn't
going to be able to deliver that such a
he's a dream to work with because he he
wants to do a great job and that's
everything right so he's willing to
sometimes we would do many many takes I
pushed him hard
um sometimes I would feel like bad I'm
like I don't want to break this guy he's
like you know he's we're jamming these
scenes in and he's working but he was
just willing to do it and willing to
just be more honest and I was learning
to be more honest as a filmmaker where
you know a lot of the stuff
and my second pass that I got was just
sort of like Ken on the streets and I
just wanted to put him in a natural
environment and kind of hide the camera
a little bit and make things feel more
alive and more honest and he was just
when they go for it and uh
I would not the movie wouldn't work
without that
um I just needed that Humanity that
Honesty from his character to
have the movie have a sense of purpose
it also like makes the satire so much
more effective because you guys do this
all the time on sunny but I always think
the the best version of a satire doesn't
fall wholeheartedly onto one side or in
the other so if the movie Just condemned
Hollywood and said that there's nothing
good to come out of this sort of place I
think it would be less effective than to
say that this relationship between the
two of you is this one bright spot of
hope within an otherwise kind of like
Bleak existence and and therefore I
think makes the satire land a lot more I
start the movie with Peter McKenzie uh
who uh we all know as the as the doctor
from Sunny who tells you that uh that
Jackie yeah obliterated
she's lucky to be alive she broke her
arm a few ribs punctured a lung
shattered her pelvis compound fractures
on both legs
her breasts excuse me
what about her breasts
I'm afraid that they were
obliterated and he is such a comedic
assassin because he plays things so
honestly yeah uh and I wanted a honest
believable doctor sort of saying that my
character we meet him in a mental health
facility at the beginning of the movie
and we we don't know what his
issue is he's lost the ability to speak
we don't know why and he's saying you
know if he can have like one meaningful
connection perhaps he can break free
from this yeah psychotic State and then
of course he delivers at a really great
line about like the state's not gonna
pay for anything put his ass on the
first bus downtown which only he can do
in that way but then the entire movie
becomes about can both these men find a
meaningful connection in Hollywood and
that turns out to be a difficult place
to find any sort of real Humanity those
were all the things that I I needed to
discover and it was just a hard path to
find it one thing it seems that you had
a grasp on from the very beginning is
you know you mentioned some of the
influences and I I 100 could see could
see them in all the best ways Woody
Allen Robert Altman Hal Ashby PT
Anderson even the best of Buster Keaton
and yes Charlie Chaplin yeah there's a
splash of it well so much of it to me
felt like anachronistic where you don't
know what time frame it actually exists
in so that makes it Timeless because
it's clearly modern times but there's a
sensibility from both the 70s and the
30s like all of all every year of
Hollywood all mashed into it yes that
was what I wanted to do with the design
with the costume design with the the
cars that I would pick for the
characters the bus at the very beginning
the boss you get dropped off and then I
got nervous for a while like making it
that like oh like this is a mistake you
know people want to know what the hell
time a movie's taking place I disagree I
think that makes that that's what makes
it feel like a fairy tale I came full
circle on it yeah but my initial
Instinct was that I wanted to sort of
satirize Hollywood Through the Ages uh
but I also knew that there were some
unbelievable aspects and heightened
aspects to the story so I thought maybe
I should from a design standpoint I
could get away with pushing things a
little further but then it got scary you
know I was like out lost in the woods in
the editing room being like is this have
I gone too far uh and then going back
and finding some stuff with Ken
emotionally grounding that
weirdly gave me more room to go further
with that stuff can we stop and talk for
one second about John Brian's score his
music I mean but that's what's so
amazing about a composer of his talent
and and also experience that he can look
at that movie and say Okay so this it
seems Timeless which with the wrong
score can be a mess yeah but he was able
to weave that in so that it feels like
it all fits together yeah you know there
were things that he scored that in my
temp track were much more upbeat and he
went he again it was like learning how
to
try to find some kind of truth even
though truth is like an elusive
abstract concept but in a movie that is
where it's all a fiction right but um he
would he he'd scored some things much
more earnestly than I had
initially done and it was absolutely the
right choice but I was kind of like
hey where are your instincts taking you
let's go explore them and I'm gonna stay
out of your way you've made great score
after great score after grade score I'm
not going to tell you how to do this
um there was some temp track stuff that
I had in that he just loved like these
old sort of uh Les Baxter and Nelson
riddle tracks which were these really
sort of full Hollywood scores the tight
the way they arranged the music they
don't do anymore
it's this is like some music theory nerd
nerd out stuff but like just the way the
chords are arranged he had these things
that we would call the Omni chords and
when you hear it has like a throwback
sound to it
where he would say oh you know should we
do this one a little more Omni and he
would start to arrange the music and I
mean I would just get more and more
blown away as he did it and then to
listen to the full Orchestra you know I
I said look I'm going to let you take
the full Orchestra and as many musicians
like what you're not going to try to cut
corners and say I gotta like double up
sounds and I'm like no just free reign
go
um and he was excited so he was
recording with old microphones and uh
yeah oh just all these tricks where he
said make sure the French horns point
the horns at the back wall so that the
sound bounces off the wall and back in
that was without him I don't know you
know you need everything to come
together
[Music]
thank you
that's why I'm making a good movie so
hard because yeah you can literally get
almost every single element right and
then you screw up one thing like the
score score doesn't work ruins the whole
yeah ruins the whole thing yeah and it's
interesting too because there's a big
sort of like Hollywood idea of like well
we can cut Corners there like let's not
spend too much on the score let's not
you know give the composer too much or
like let's just throw in some and you
know if you think about all your
favorite movies music is such a big part
of why the movie Works
um John Williams I mean yeah look at
John Williams and take all the music out
of Star Wars yeah you know they've done
that right people have done that where
they pull yeah pull all the music out
and watch it you're like it doesn't work
yeah Jaws where the mechanical shark's
not working and then he's like well what
if you just hear that and now we just
associate those two notes with sharks
incredible
um I I do think that uh I mean talk
about a man who doesn't want to hear a
compliment I do think John Bryan is up
there in terms of that level of talent I
was like uh yeah no he's so so talented
thank you
[Music]
oh guys today the show is brought to you
by our friends at mint mobile well from
Rob's friends at mint mobile well now
hang on a second Rob's friend at mint
mobile okay well today the show is
brought to you by Rob's singular friend
at mint mobile he actually sold it but
um they turned out well for him because
he found a way uh for mint mobile to
make him money too and guess what it can
make money for you because you can make
money for us because I want some of the
money that he made for it minted him a
bunch of money it could make me money I
meant me money is it is it because mint
mobile offers premium Wireless on on the
nation's largest 5G Network for only 15
a month no no no no I'm no expert here
but what are you talking about 15 a
month what what's the catch well there
actually is no catch mints the first
company to sell a wireless service
solely online they cut the cost of
retail stores and passed the savings
directly onto you and they give you the
best possible rate for you and for your
family which could just be two people
what do you mean what do you mean like
like uh do you know anybody who's well
Jade you know uh who from our ad sales
uh is a single mom and she's made enough
money or saved enough money from mint
mobile that she's planning on taking her
kid on a trip this year okay so to get
your new Wireless plan and for just 15
bucks a month that's right it's crazy 15
bucks a month wow okay and get that plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
Sunny that is
mintmobile.com sunny cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
Sunny
did you know that for every minute a new
seller around the world makes their
first sale
on Shopify it's packed with
industry-leading tools and an extensive
Business course Library so you can gain
more confidence and control over your
brand without having to learn any coding
or design skills it's there to empower
you to reach reach the next level
whether you're selling handmade
miniature
symbols little things you know what I
mean little tiny things Sunny podcast
merch right like we do the more you're
selling way star royco to Gojo you know
oh hang on a second Shopify can help
close Billion Dollar Deals like on
succession big deals baby it can make
you a killer like Daddy always wanted
you to be glendal Roy
yeah we're really gonna be close those
kinds of multi-billion Dollar Deals this
is yeah you know this is more for the
99.9 percent of self-made business
people out there who want to sell their
goods so if you were to say uh I don't
know Market uh brand of t-shirts and
trinkets that say [__] off well that's
shopify's bread and butter isn't it I
shouldn't deliver it or delivered it uh
more like [__] off yeah [__] off isn't
that kind of how he says it yeah so
anyway I just want to be clear about
that yeah sign up for a one dollar per
month trial period at shopify.com Sunny
all lowercase go to shopify.com
Sunny to take your business to the next
level today are you listening to what
Charlie just said I just said it
shopify.com sunny are you listening
shopify.com Sunny are you listening yeah
go that's if you're not [__] off [__]
off
laughs
[Music]
they're bingsley may I come in what the
hell God I flew name is that I answered
one name and one name only
and that's Billy the Kid
all right
Billy the Kid wow hang up
don't drop the third part now excuse me
sir Billy the Kid I think that gonna
suit me just fine got kind of a nice
ring to it don't it how about you call
me that from now on all right yeah make
an announcement to whoever y'all was out
there right it's sir Billy The Kid From
now on listen to me [__] face you're
either a sir and an actor from England
or you're Billy the [__] kid but you
can't be both let's talk a little bit
about Glenn's performance in the movie
but that's the thing that honestly is
the thing that made us laugh the most
and I went around it and watched it
again and that just shows a few things
one how much we love Glenn but be how
our sense of humor is very specific and
I don't know what the rest of the
audience is gonna fight at the funniest
scene I thought it was the funniest well
I tell you what I I've screened the
movie you know a few times not like with
an audience um like uh you know in color
stages and whatever and you always get a
huge laugh whether people know sunny or
they don't because you're a great great
performer and it's a funny scene and you
nailed it and you did a choice that was
like oh this is what you want to do but
let's go for it well we yeah cause it
wasn't the character wasn't written with
an accent and I just had this I just had
this funny idea of like what Kate and I
were trying to identify the actor you
can't you can't the whole thing was what
I was attempting was like the bra it was
what I was calling a European accent
which you know isn't a thing obviously
at one point I was gonna I don't think I
wound up changing your credit to
European business manager vaguely
European finale European oh that's right
yeah it was like I wanted to do I wanted
it to be like where is this person from
but you know it wasn't it was great
because it really wound up playing into
the tone of like identity yeah and
you're like it worked out nicely yeah
what not not what I was I mean I was
just thinking I don't know it just kind
of struck me it wasn't like I was making
a choice based on what I felt like it
would fit in with the movie watching
something that made it interesting to me
was to just make him vaguely or pan now
you crushing the movie I and uh it was
fun there's lots of Sunny uh things that
there's so many sunny people and Easter
eggs
anyone so we might not catch uh Sunny
fans are gonna have lots of to chew on
oh Jillian Bell's not a sunny actor but
she feels like one she's amazing she's
amazing it's amazing um the [__] she's
singing
which wasn't in my first cut Leslie
found that I somehow missed that I was
like oh this is great she's like singing
something about like yeah yeah
beige banana
um funny well you did a great job thanks
you did a great job exciting for people
to see this I'm very excited what's the
date again
May 12th May 12th is a day it's the same
day go out to the goddamn theaters you
[__] creeps this is a movie I would I
would personally want to see it in the
theater if I wasn't doing or involved in
it like I miss comedies in the theater I
miss like laughing with a group of
people like why do we think
why does the industry think people don't
want that anymore maybe they don't want
as much as they want a Marvel movie but
they still want it like don't take it
away completely anyway you have a chance
to go see in the theater you also have a
chance to go see Blackberry starring
Glenn Howerton now let's get into this
okay guys 250. here's what I'm gonna do
I will give you twenty thousand dollars
cash today I'll sell the phone I'll work
out this problem with USR but I want 50
of the company
and I've got to be CEO
that's are you joking no what was it
obviously obviously no no you should
digest it Mike okay okay who is in
charge here well let me set this up for
the audience a little bit so the movie's
about the making of the Blackberry which
was for our young audience predated the
iPhone as the device that really
put emails and internet on a phone and
sort of was the Breakthrough thing and a
fantastic device and a fantastic device
and um but just got just crushed by the
iPhone but um I always like a movie and
and Glenn plays sort of a the
businessman who helps The Tech Guys take
this from just an idea to uh a
successful business I always enjoy a
movie about a real life event it's
inherently interesting right because
you're like it's like you're looking at
a time machine you're getting to see the
past but it was so second to me then the
real magic trick of this film which was
a filmmaker finally giving Glenn
Howerton
that the chance to take on a rich and
dynamic character and uh with with the
training wheels completely off I mean
the character starts at a 10. but we
like seeing Glenn Howerton out of 10.
what the [__] is happening will you
accept your charges
still there yeah yes I I accept thank
you
Mike hi there are three reasons why
people buy our phones you know what they
are for email they [__] work but
every
inch of the of the movie every frame
that you are in is so compelling my only
complaint is that you are not in every
single segment of the film and by the
way you're in the majority of the film
so no one's not going to get a full dose
of you but I could have watched that guy
brush his teeth I could I could have
watched the story of that guy from the
beginning to end and I like the other
story too I like the movie a lot of
movies great but holy [__] man you're so
[__] good oh man thank you yeah and I
just want I want so much more of that I
want more movies like that in fact I was
jealous watching it be like why didn't I
make a Glenn Harrison movie where I
where I have you like in every scene
doing your thing let me sell the movie
again to be just because I want people
to go see the movie and not just Glenn's
performance the the they end with a
Chiron that's not giving anything away
everybody already knows this it says and
this is considering at this point there
was a massive amount of different cell
phone companies that were out there the
razors and the nokias of the world and
and and all sorts of different cellular
companies that were coming out in
carriers and it was the Wild West it was
before Android really came into
existence it was before the iPhone had
come into existence and and Blackberry
had 45 of the market cap I mean almost
half of everybody in the world that had
a mobile phone had a Blackberry in 2009
or eight or whatever it was and now that
number is zero zero yeah so this movie
is tracking the beginning
and the rise of this massive company and
then it's inevitable crash and to take a
movie that that's like an inherently
exciting story but you're not used to
hearing about stories about a business
being fascinating and this feels like a
thriller yeah almost you're watching us
knowing that going in doesn't make it
any less exciting to watch that no well
you know you know that in your pocket
you have an iPhone yeah and that so
you're either old enough to remember
Blackberry or you're not but to hear
that they at one point had 50 of the mar
of the market now and now everybody's
walking around with these that's what
the story is really about and how these
disparate personalities were able to
build that and then not able to beat the
iPhone there was no bad guy it seemed at
one point that Glenn's character was the
bad guy but in the end they all had
fallibility that was a really
interesting aspect of that movie that
each one of them
there wasn't like a sort of redeeming
ending you're like but you know well
maybe the the what's the character with
the headband um maybe they said like
okay he was sort of our good guy sort of
because without but but the argument
could be made that without the other two
Doug's success doesn't exist either
unless the carriers rebuild their entire
networks there's nothing we can do the
phones use too much data well then
[__] shrink it yeah okay
um
we we looked into that uh-huh
these guys can't do it
what do you mean they can't do it you
said they were the best engineers in the
world I said they're the best engineers
in Canada
okay all right
who could do it
maybe top guys from Motorola or
Microsoft or Google
okay
what are you doing who else where else
John Carmack
get John Carmack from ID
do you guys hear me
the guy who may do
what's Doom
have you played Wolfenstein
please just don't sell anymore folks
can you hear me yes yes oh
there's something about your performance
that makes it very clear that you are
right even though you're unlikable that
either something
is really really good at what he does
because you want to watch you're playing
a guy who's clearly he's got
the anger issues and he's emotionally
unstable but he's good so it's a
gunslinger right like you know he's the
best Gunslinger in town so you want to
watch him and that's always a really
good sort of narrative to be like can I
watch the expert do his be an expert at
it and we want to see you manipulate
people well you know what's funny is I
had the same fear going into this
that I had in early days of Sunny where
I was like
he's going to be so unlikable that
you're not and I was like I think you do
need to be rooting for this guy
and yet you know he has to be so
ruthless and and you did hit the nail on
that I mean the main thing is he is
incredibly competitive the real Jim is
incredibly competitive and I think he to
default it destroys him yes it destroys
him and and he had but he had to be in
order to build that company the way that
he did but and he's not the reason that
it fails
he's not really the reason they they
suggest some of the Shady dealing
business dealings which everybody was
doing at that time he's not the reason
he was not the Visionary there was a
Visionary who didn't see that there was
a better Vision out there Mike did not
Mike was not doing his job properly
right he was the one who was meant to
see where the market was headed that's
what he did so well when he created the
Blackberry and he was so uh enamored of
his own invention that he didn't see
that somebody was about to take his
lunch and that's then you're right
because my character the whole time is
like Mike
wait are you doing your thing you do
your thing I'm doing that I'm I'm out
here selling phones I'm doing my thing
are you making the thing that we need to
be selling you know yeah but you know
here's the thing about likability I it's
the same thing with sunny that we always
did which is that if can I understand
their want and because we know your want
you know you've taken out you're alone
you've mortgaged your own house and we
know that you want and you're not being
taken seriously enough within your
business when we meet your character
yeah and we know that you know you refer
to the people you're like this this
great lives like why did they fire you
you know you nail it you're like because
they're idiots you know um with no sort
of wink to the line just like pure just
like that's a fact uh but we know your
want and we identify with your wants so
you can be an [__] you can be a
ruthless but we know you want this thing
and we know you're in some ways you
deserve it because you are good at what
you do so the most likability is it's
just the wrong word to describe the
thing that people yeah and it's it is a
character compelling or not and what
makes a person compelling and being nice
and polite and likable are social
constructs that are [__] [__] and
don't belong in narrative it's not what
makes people interested what movies are
have that you know yeah there's no
inherent conflict but you still it's
like to me it's less about likability
more about rootability like I knew that
you needed to be rooting for this guy
you didn't need to necessarily like him
but you did need to be rooting for him
on some level
um but but the thing is is like through
my experience of of you know playing
such a horrible person on it's always
sunny I really I I I I allowed myself to
go to that place and to be right on the
edge almost of of rootability just
because in my experience you're right it
is it is I was like it just it'll be
compelling you know it'll be interesting
to watch and I think you'll understand
where he's coming from if I do my job
right like if you see if you can see the
thoughts that are going through my head
the calculations that I'm making but
also like I had a tremendous amount of
trust in in Matt Johnson yeah who's who
wrote and directed the movie he wrote it
with his uh producing partner Matt
Miller
um they wrote the movie together and he
he directed it um and of course accident
plays Doug
um and it's just yeah I know that sorry
yeah the guy who played Doug director oh
my God he's such a dummy in the movie
that yes oh he's an assassins wow
um so uh
um we've been talking here
and we
um
we would like to make a counteroffer he
came crawling back
like bugs like grubs yep
um so we would like to offer you
10 percent
for
five hundred thousand dollars are you
[__] mind I look at a hundred
thousand deals a day
I look at 100 deals a day I pick one
Wall Street he's an incredibly smart guy
I mean when I read the script I was like
this this script is so it's so smart
it's so well done yeah you know and then
in talking to him and seeing his
previous uh films I I felt like I could
trust that if I wasn't doing the right
thing that would though the thing that
was gonna make the best version of the
movie that he would have told me so I
just kind of like you said I took the
training wheels off and just was like
I'm gonna I'm gonna do what I think is
right here and let's let's just see what
happens
foreign
that's right we're sponsored by
everyone's favorite uh Green drink
powder that's athletic greens yeah no
one hears a stranger to athletic greens
or they're delicious ag1 powder but we
never Tire of singing their praises with
one scoop of ag1 you're absorbing 75 75.
high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Food sourced superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens adaptogens here's a pro tip
the best time to do it to take ag1 is in
the morning on an empty stomach you just
know breakfast no coffee just drink ag1
and then wait about 10 minutes before
you eat anything you feel that sensation
of what do they call it being alive oh
yeah is the best sensation there is man
because I personally I went from being
on a mostly plant diet to a mostly meat
diet okay let's be honest you know which
changed almost all my meals but never
once did I miss my daily dose of ag-1 I
got to get my greens right so I gotta
get my meat gotta have the greens
of the balance yeah well you gotta have
good gut health and ag-1 really helps
with gut health well that's because it's
backed by the latest science with
constant product iterations and
third-party testing so you know you're
always getting the best of the best
that's right ag1 make your vitamins
better than everyone else's vitamins to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athletic greens.com Sunny that's right
again that's athletic greens.com Sunny
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
[Music]
well uh-huh uh I was hoping Rob was
going to be here today but we're missing
the hot takes of Rob Justice I gotta say
well yeah but moreover I need to I need
Clarity on whether we're getting these
tickets to the wrecks of Manchester
United game in July I want those tickets
I know it's still like a ways away but
um
yeah I feel like the tickets are gonna
go quickly and I don't want them to go
without me having them I want the good
ones you know what I mean the good ones
they go if it comes down to the wire you
guys could always get them on Game Time
say what
uh
okay tell me more about game time oh
I've actually heard of that now now that
I'm thinking of it yeah you know they
have that app where you can get epic
last minute ticket Bargains wait this is
fantastic okay so you don't have to wait
for tickets to go on sale and try to
hoard through the millions of fans that
are trying to get them no now I wait
until right before sometimes even day of
and I always land the best seat left in
the house that's great don't wear
yourself out running up and down the
field you know just sit back and you
wait to strike on goal when it's your
time you know what I mean
sorry I thought that would impress Rob
yeah yeah he's not he's not here so snag
your tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code Sunny for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code Sunny for 20 bucks off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
foreign
I also want to compliment you I feel
like
two three lines in
there was no dentist to me there was no
Glenn you know like obviously you see
your friend you're bald I know you're
not bald I know you're not a man in
Canada so you know like well he was he
wasn't man I know you're not a man from
Canada you don't care for hockey
um uh there's you know obviously there's
always that thing in a movie where
you're like well that's uh you know
that's Sean Penn doing a limp and a wig
but like
two two three lines in and you're just
in and you are that guy and you're
consistent from beginning to end how did
I have two questions performing can I
speak to that can I speak to that
because because I think you both you
guys both accomplish that
um that I was most impressed with to
Charlie's point you you do this long
enough and your friends are acting and
things and you see them and it's hard to
distance yourself because you're
spending so much time with them off
camera and you're seeing them pull out
the tricks that we all use we know all
the moves yes and so I'm used to seeing
every move that you have in every move
that you have that's why I think and we
didn't talk about this at all but how
fascinating it is that one of the one of
the defining characteristics of you as a
performer and you as a person is is your
actual voice which is so distinct and
fascinating and to Meg touched on this a
little bit but to take that away from
yourself I think was very brave because
it's a crutch that you can use and it's
also a tool that you can use to express
yourself your voice but it also was so
smart because because it took it took
you as a performer as a person and made
you completely
um unrecognizable to me as I'm watching
it because I'm I'm watching you going
well that still looks like Charlie but
it certainly doesn't sound like Charlie
and he's doing something I've never seen
you do before Oh thanks man and and with
Glenn
um yeah the baldness like the it wasn't
the look it was no it was the delivery
and your eyes dude I was looking in your
eyes I'm like I've never seen Glenn make
that expression before yeah it was cold
calculated killer and Dennis is not even
though we don't know he's not like that
no it's not Dennis Reynolds at all and
it's not Glenn Howerton being angry
it's that character now let me ask you
this did you meet with the guy did you
base any stuff off him because you're
playing a real person which is
interesting yeah uh no actually
um I only had there's a couple things uh
I really only had about three three and
a half weeks to prep for that movie so I
knew I had to make it I knew I didn't
have time to do all the research that
you would want to do ultimately in most
ideal circumstances and also prepare the
actual Performance Based on the material
so you know Matt and I both felt very
strongly that you know Jim he's known a
little bit he's known in Canada but most
people don't know him he hasn't given a
lot of on-camera interviews but he
doesn't have a lot of like yeah people
don't know what he's really like what
his tics are what he sounds like and you
know what his you know uh body language
is like most people just don't know what
that is and we just felt like that was
less important to focus on I also knew
that Matt and Matt had done so much
research you know they they interviewed
countless ex-employees and all these
things to to really find out who these
characters were and what they were like
you know so I really tried to just focus
on on the character that I was reading
in the script and and what I felt like
that that character should should come
off as but uh but I did
event I did meet the real gym
recently in Toronto yeah so he had been
sent the film uh he watched it
um he actually did an interview and kind
of responded you know and for the most
part was like very like very
complimentary of the film and you know
had had a couple gripes about the way
things went down he's like that's not
really how it went down you know
um which is understandable but uh but
then he came to the Toronto Premiere and
I met him before the premiere and he was
he was he was lovely it was it was a
super I was nervous to meet him sure you
know what I mean because I was like
because it's a ruthless performance I
want to meet the man that I played I
don't want to meet the man not you know
what I'm saying I don't want to meet the
person that I was portraying because
because he was scary he's kind of scary
yeah yeah he's kind of scary um but he
was he was lovely he was lovely yeah
he's very he can be a very Charming guy
too
um and then he watched the premiere with
an audience and and I think he really
enjoyed it you know seeing it with an
audience I think it really came alive
for him more than watching it by himself
and he told me he said that's the oh
this he was like going into it he said
this this will be the only time I've
ever seen a movie more than once
how did you
um did you and Mike like work really
closely on figuring out the levels
because you know you you make a movie
you don't shoot it in sequence right you
shoot because of the locations you might
be shooting the last scene first you're
you're bouncing all around so
was it
difficult to track where to be with this
guy emotionally because
you know you I'm sure you wanted to be
aware of how often you were out of 10
you know and yeah when to play them down
how did you guys navigate that it seems
to me like you were always when the
character walked into a room
he was at an eight mm-hmm yeah but it
was really sibling really compelling
because you don't know when it's going
to go to a 10 at any moment but it's an
eight not of anger but of anxiety like
controlled anxiety and rage that's just
sitting right under the surface and
ready and everybody around you so the
Audi every character like sits up
straighter and everybody in the audience
is can't wait to see how Jim's going to
react in this moment right you know for
as much experience as we all have like
on on camera
uh and and acting with lights and a boom
operator and make up people all over you
and all this [__] like a lot of a lot of
very comfortable on camera
at this point but what I don't actually
have a lot of experience with almost no
experience actually is scoring a film
performance yeah because in TV your
character doesn't really change and
after you've done two or three episodes
you know the character so well you know
I don't I could slip into the dentist
that like that like it's just it's just
like like the flip of a switch you know
so the challenge becomes how do I get
myself to the point where I feel the
same way walking on the set playing gym
as I do playing Dennis who I've played
for 13 years how can I maximize the
three and a half weeks that I have to
prepare for this so that I feel just as
comfortable playing gem as I do playing
Dennis and they're two completely
different human beings and Jim's totally
both characters are totally different
than than I am there's aspects of course
there have to be I'm pulling from my own
experience my own life and all that kind
of stuff but but scoring a performance
that was a real challenge for me I
really you know what I did I I took the
very anything that Anthony Hopkins said
years and years and years ago and I
really was like okay I think that that's
a really good place to start which is
just read the script over and over yeah
over for sure over and over because
unlike Sunny we have you know you didn't
write this one so when we're writing
Sunday yeah yeah yeah the amount of
weeks and months that have gone into
writing that episode you just know it so
well you might forget like some of the
lot the specific lines but you know why
the character wants what they want in
each moment but your characters our
characters don't have an arc so either
way it doesn't matter as much but you're
right your character has to you know
start in one place and end in a
different place
um so I was just reading the script over
and over again and having a lot of
conversations with Matt about
Matt Johnson about
um each scene and sort of what he was
picturing and finding out that for the
most part we were almost always on the
same page right about the way it would
play
um but you know Matt also shot it in a
way uh where the coverage was very
simple
and we could play with it so there were
a lot of variations of those scenes that
you know that mostly handheld right like
I'm very documentary what they did is
they shot it on a oh forgetting the name
of this thing okay so this is what this
was the way he shot the movie was super
super interesting I almost never knew
where the cameras were wow
he would have a camera
like
it's a long lens so like a hundred feet
away on a long lens and I I was always
asking like where where's the camera
he's like he's like it's over there and
I'd be like what it's like Wildlife
photography yeah it was like that's
exactly what it was it was wildlife and
what they did is they put it on
um
God I'm forgetting the name of this
thing but basically it was on a a tripod
but on the tripod there was a ball this
ball this like bouncy ball a gimbal a
gimbal it was a gimbal so they could
they could hold it and have it
you know because you don't want to be
you can't be that you can't be handheld
when you're on that long of a lens yeah
anyone who knows anything too shaky it
gets too shaky but on a gimbal you can
add just a little bit of a handheld feel
to it and have it feel handheld even
though it it wasn't technically handheld
I give it that Thriller feel you're
talking about and and that's that that's
one of the things that I really love
about the movie watching it too because
I is that it does it's like a really
interesting mix of like you feel like
you're watching a thriller and yet it is
funny but it's not overtly comedic but
it is funny yeah um it's just like a
good example of you know how when care
you play it real but the the the it's so
outrageous I think that's where a lot of
the comedy was coming from for for Matt
and for us it was like the more
outrageous this is the the the funnier
it is and and but it was it's all based
on real [__] but I mean I I I I
definitely was not approaching this as a
as a comedy at all I'm so glad you
didn't I think uh any wink to that
character would
it wouldn't hurt the movie you know the
fact that you played it dramatic and
serious just it drives the story I have
a prediction the prediction is this
within a month of this movie coming out
the phone is going to be ringing for
Glenn out and I can tell you just
anecdotally I've already told you this
but I was at a football game with Sean
Levy the director and he came up to me
and said I just have to tell you I saw
this movie called the Blackberry movie
and your friend Glenn is amazing in it
can you tell him I said he's amazing and
I said [__] you you tell them you tell
him and he's like I want to cast him in
something I'm like definitely tell him
that so so many times over the years we
feel like I certainly feel like our cast
is overlooked when it comes to Casting
some of these movies and I see some of
these jerk offs that get these movies
I'm like what how are these people being
cast in this when we have these people
on our show and I'm just glad and I I'm
just glad that people are finally
recognizing that for both of you guys
and like I'm 17 years
but we're getting there
you deserve it for sure it does
frustrate me like and it will frustrate
me like
when people are like and Glenn is really
good in this movie who knew oh like who
knew well I think I think that that is
that that is Shifting yeah I know I do
think that that is that is Shifting and
and I'm happy to see that happening and
I have a theory about that but we can't
get into it now because we're out of
time but uh but I appreciate you guys
watching the movie and and uh
um and I'm glad that I took I felt like
I was taking a big swing but I wouldn't
have been able to take that big swing if
I didn't know that if if I failed
miserably I wouldn't have this to fall
back on
not just economically but emotionally
emotionally yes and I was a reminder of
your trampoline speech like but I
wouldn't have had the confidence to take
that backflip if you weren't there yeah
yeah yeah exactly which resulted in you
talking about how you licked a little
bit it wasn't great but it was fine it
was fine
so you're licking somebody's [__] on
a trampoline and I'm wondering why
you're not getting cast in mainstream
yeah yeah yeah
May 12th everybody go out see double
feature now I will say that I wrote
directed uh financially engaged it's
been 10 years of my life yeah and Glenn
is also in my movie yeah so please see
that one first please see that because
it's a win-win for Glenn either way I'm
proud of you guys thanks man I'm proud
of you guys let's make some more stuff
together let's keep doing it